[Música]
rusia tendría que pagar costos severos y
va de a ucrania así lo advirtió el
presidente de estadounidense joe biden
tras hablar telefónicamente con su
homólogo ruso vladimir putin este es el
tercer contacto entre los mandatarios en
los últimos dos meses
la policía de canadá comenzó a
desbloquear el puente que conecta a ese
país con eeuu tras una orden judicial
del viernes sin embargo los camioneros
todavía están en el paso fronterizo
protestando contra las medidas del hobby
y precisamente los transportistas
protagonizaron las manifestaciones
contra las medidas frente al coronavirus
el fenómeno que comenzó en canadá con el
llamado convoy de la libertad ahora se
replica con vehículos bloqueando vías en
francia países bajos entre otros
buenas noches y bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 mi nombre es maría
clara calle el presidente de estados
unidos joe biden habló telefónicamente
con su homólogo ruso vladimir putin
durante poco más de una hora y luego de
esto dejó un tono de amenaza desde la
casa blanca al kremlin vaivén le
advirtió a putin que su país está listo
para otros escenarios si la diplomacia
falla en ucrania todo esto es una puja
diplomática en la que todavía no hay un
acuerdo para la desescalada en las
tensiones fronterizas mientras que el
pentágono enviará 3.000 tropas
adicionales a polonia y las fuerzas
rusas realizan ejercicios militares
cerca de ucrania marinas ardilla tiene
la historia
un nuevo intento de apaciguar la
atención global a través de la
diplomacia pero con una clara
advertencia desde washington si el
kremlin invadió ucrania el presidente
baiden habló hoy con el presidente
vladimir putin para dejar claro que si
rusia continúa invadiendo ucrania eeuu y
nuestros aliados impondrán sanciones
económicas rápidas y severas a rusia es
el tercer contacto entre el mandatario
estadounidense y su homólogo ruso en los
últimos dos meses sin que aún hayan
llegado a un cambio fundamental para la
des escalada en la frontera
ruso-ucraniana
eeuu se mantiene firme en sus amenazas
alegando estar preparado para otros
escenarios si la vía diplomática fracasa
lo que tendría un alto sufrimiento
humano desde moscú confirmaron el
compromiso del kremlin de continuar con
los contactos a todos los niveles pero
rechazan las afirmaciones
estadounidenses de un ataque ruso
inminente
pero vinieron la
histeria ha alcanzado su punto máximo
las tensiones en torno a los movimientos
de nuestras tropas en nuestro territorio
aunque no estén lejos de las fronteras
de ucrania se han calentado durante
muchos meses en los últimos días y en
horas se han vuelto absurdas
washington también inició el
desmantelamiento del personal de su
embajada en kiev y el viernes varias
naciones de occidente pidieron a sus
ciudadanos que abandonen el país ante
los señalamientos estadounidenses de un
alto riesgo de una incursión rusa unas
declaraciones que están lejos de
apaciguar las tensiones en canadá a la
policía ya comenzó a desbloquear el
puente ambassador que es el principal
paso fronterizo entre el país y eeuu
durante cinco días consecutivos los
transportistas han atravesado sus
vehículos para protestar en contra de
las restricciones de kobe 19 por las que
deben estar vacunados o entrar en
cuarentena al ingresar a suelo
canadiense el viernes una orden judicial
advirtió que bloquear el puente es un
delito aquí les contamos qué está
ocurriendo
un enfrentamiento entre los
manifestantes y la policía las
autoridades han comenzado a despejar el
bloqueo del principal paso fronterizo de
ontario entre canadá y eeuu tras dos
semanas de manifestaciones de camioneros
contra las medidas de kobe de los
agentes han instado a los manifestantes
a que se dispersen o se enfrenten a
multas la pérdida del permiso de
conducir e incluso a penas de cárcel
después de que el viernes se presentara
una orden judicial contra el bloqueo del
puente ambassador muchos manifestantes
están decididos a no moverse
esto lo es insurrección y terrorismo
esto es gente de base con sus hijos y
sus abuelos y padres uniéndose y
diciendo oye mis derechos y libertades
están siendo infringido y negados aquí
mis hijos no merecen esto no merecen ver
esto no merecen esto para su futuro se
merecen la libertad
el llamado convoy de la libertad fue
iniciado por camioneros canadienses en
protesta por la exigencia de vacunación
o cuarentena a los conductores que
cruzan la frontera con eeuu el primer
ministro justin todos se ha enfrentado a
una creciente presión para intervenir en
su país y también desde washington ya
que el bloqueo de la principal ruta
comercial ha obligado a los productores
de automóviles de ambos países a detener
o reducir la producción las multitudes
también siguen manifestándose en el
centro de la capital ottawa mientras que
otros dos pasos fronterizos con eeuu
también están siendo bloqueados por los
manifestantes
este fenómeno del llamado convoy de la
libertad que comenzó en canadá como lo
veíamos en la nota se está replicando ya
en varios países del mundo en francia
hoy la policía lanzó gases lacrimógenos
contra los manifestantes en la avenida
de los campos elíseos y es que decenas
de automóviles superaron los controles
policiales que estaban sobre parís
lograron entorpecer el tráfico alrededor
del arco del crimen
en la haya también hubo camiones
bloqueando el paso para rechazar las
medidas que el gobierno neerlandés ha
tomado contra el kobe 19 los
manifestantes tocaron la bocina y
bloquearon la entrada al histórico
complejo parlamentario de esta ciudad de
países bajos todo con el eslogan amor y
libertad no dictadura
en alemania también hubo protestas pero
los manifestantes iban a pie en
fráncfort cerca de 2.800 personas
empezaron en contra de la vacunación
obligatoria y es que el viernes el
tribunal superior de alemania rechazó
las peticiones de emergencia que pedían
que se cancelará el esquema completo
contra el kobe 19 es obligatorio para el
personal de salud
en canberra australia también se
manifestaron en contra de la vacunación
contra el coronavirus bloqueando las
vías el primer ministro australiano
scott morrison respondió pidiéndoles que
protestarán de manera pacífica y
respetuosa
seis personas de la misma familia
murieron en un bombardeo mientras
estaban afuera de su casa disfrutando
una tarde soleada estos hechos
ocurrieron en una aldea en el noroeste
de síria que es controlada por los
rebeldes la defensa civil conocida como
los cascos blancos fue la que hizo la
denuncia y agregó que dos de los
fallecidos eran niños de tres y de siete
años según este grupo en los últimos
seis meses han muerto 65 menores de edad
en una nueva campaña de bombardeos del
gobierno sirio respaldado por rusia
el sistema de salud libanés se está
desplomando en medio de la crisis
económica esto ha provocado un éxodo de
miles de médicos y de enfermeras se
calcula que alrededor del 40% del
personal clínico que es entre 2000
enfermeras y 1000 médicos ya han
abandonado el líbano todo para buscar
mejores oportunidades en europa y en los
países del golfo
escenas como estas se han convertido en
lo cotidiano en la clínica el doctor
mario north ja
no se puede dar el lujo de perder
pacientes con la crisis económica la
super inflación y la crisis energética
este dentista ha perdido el 70 por
ciento de sus ingresos ahora trabaja
solo porque no pudo pagar al personal en
ningún otro lugar estamos trabajando de
manera tan precaria no podemos cobrar a
los pacientes en dólares pero compramos
todo el material clínico en dólares y
sólo podemos trabajar en las horas con
electricidad por lo que tenemos menos
pacientes donar
cada vez es más difícil encontrar
especialistas en el líbano muchos ganan
al mes menos de 150 dólares la doctora
lina trabaja en tres hospitales y tiene
una consulta privada pero aún así no es
suficiente para mantenerse no puedo
subir les las tarifas a los padres de
mis pacientes todo el mundo está aquí
atravesando fuertes dificultades
económicas mis hijos están estudiando en
la universidad y no querríamos irnos
pero el futuro es muy oscuro marilina
forman parte de ese grupo de médicos que
todavía resisten en el líbano mientras
un 40 por ciento de sus colegas ha
optado por emigrar a otros países el
éxodo de médicos ha obligado a los
hospitales privados a tener que reducir
o cerrar servicios lo que representa una
amenaza para la población en tiempos de
pandemia
el sector salud se ha visto muy afectado
con la migración de médicos por la
crisis económica estamos corriendo un
alto riesgo con el covent 19 la
capacidad de los hospitales se ha
reducido a un 40% y tenemos muchas
dificultades logísticas
el líbano ha sido reconocido durante
décadas como el hospital de medio
oriente por sus tecnologías y
especialistas pero ahora quedan pocos
médicos que apuestan por un futuro sin
profesionales que lo sustenten el
sistema de salud libanés será una
víctima más de las múltiples crisis que
afronta el país
comienzan las celebraciones anuales del
carnaval de venecia en italia después de
un año de haberla suspendido a causa de
la pandemia del cob y 19 y es que a
medida que la tasa de contagios de
coronavirus ha disminuido en territorio
italiano las autoridades permitieron el
festejo y de hecho lo llaman el carnaval
de la esperanza cerca de 50.000 personas
viajaron hasta venecia para mirar las
tradicionales máscaras de estas fiestas
irán hasta el próximo primero de marzo
y así llegamos al final de nuestra
emisión ustedes sigan conectados a
france 24
[Música]